yes mr. jobs you're a brightening man
here it comes
sad and clear that I've ever encountered
disgust you don't know what you're
talking about
I would like for example for you to
express in clear terms how say Java in
any of its incarnations addresses the
ideas embodied and opened up and when
you're finished with that perhaps you
could tell us what you personally have
been doing for the last seven years you
know you can please some of the people
some of the time but
one of the hardest things when you're
trying to affect change is that people
like this gentleman are right in some
areas I'm sure that there are some
things opendoc does probably even more
than I'm not familiar with that nothing
else out there does and I'm sure that
you can make some demos maybe a small
commercial app that demonstrates those
things the hardest thing is what how
does that fit in to a cohesive larger
vision that's going to allow you to sell
eight billion dollars 10 billion dollars
of product a year and one of the things
I've always found is that you've got to
start with the customer experience and
work backwards to the technology you
can't start with the technology and try
to figure out where you're going to try
to sell it and I've made this mistake
probably more than anybody else in this
room and I got the scar tissue to prove
it and I know that it's the case and as
we have tried to come up with a strategy
and a vision for Apple it started with
what incredible benefits can we give to
the customer where can we take the
customer not not starting with let's sit
down with the engineers and and figure
out what awesome technology we have and
then how are we going to market that and
I think that's the right path to take I
remember with the laser writer we built
the world's first small laser printers
you know and there was awesome
technology in that box we have the first
canon laser printing cheap laser
printing engine in the world in the
United States here at Apple we had a
very wonderful printer controller that
we design
we had Adobe's PostScript software in
there we had Apple talk in there just
awesome technology in the box and I
remember seeing the first printout come
out of it and just picking it up and
looking at anything you know we can sell
this because you don't have to know
anything about what's in that box
all we have to do is hold of something
good you want this and if you remember
back to 1984 before laser printers
it was pretty startling to see that
people went wow yes and that's that's
where Apple's got to get back to and you
know I'm sorry that opened docks a
casualty along the way and I readily
admit there are many things in life that
I don't the faintest idea what I'm
talking about so I apologize for that
too but there's a whole lot of people
working super super hard right now at
Apple you know AVI John Marino Fred I
mean the whole team is working burning
the midnight oil trying to and people
you know hundreds of people below them
to execute on some of these things and
they're doing their best and I think
that what we need to do and some
mistakes will be made by the way some
mistakes will be made along the way
that's good because at least some
decisions are being made along the way
and we'll find the mistakes we'll fix
them and I think what we need to do is
support that team going through this
very important stage as they work their
butts off they're all getting calls
being offered three times as much money
to go do this without the valley's hot
none of them are leaving and I think we
need to support them and see them
through this and write some damn good
applications to support Apple out in the
market that's my own point of view
mistakes we made some people will be
pissed off some people will not know
what they're talking about but it's I
think it is so much better than where
things were not very long ago and I
think we're gonna get there